um we did covered broadly but it I think
people don't realize that you that most
counties in America that I adopted what
they call the IRB see codes which is the
international residential building codes
and those codes are they're called the
International building codes but they're
primarily adopted in America I think
maybe in Canada to some extent but and
those because they're all adopted some
variation of those codes those code that
that's the code that really needs to be
changed because that's the one that has
the minimum house sizes and it has the
you know it sort of stipulates certain
sizes for each type of room like a
kitchen should be X by X and living room
X bags and you know if you have this
much square footage you need to lose
this many rooms and you know things like
that that kind of get in the way of
creative housing structures yeah and I
think I mean beyond is creativity to you
know there are obstacles to not sure you
know what the codes necessarily are in
LA but you know in a lot of places like
if we wanted to take you know our tiny
house to Denver you know for example
it's it's harder and a lot of urban
areas or in Boulder proper you know it's
they have codes against having temporary
structures and backyards and and things
like that and so it's it's harder to
find a place to put your tiny house in a
lot of urban areas and then also from an
insurance perspective there's actually a
woman up in the northwest that we just
learned about who I was almost done
building her tiny house and she had a
fire and it burned down and the tiny
house community has sort of risen up and
there's a lot of fundraising going on to
sort of help her rebuild the tiny house
but you know because they're sort of you
know not traditional structures it's
really hard to get insurance to cover a
tiny house and that's something that
would be great to see changes will also
people can be a little bit more
protected in a lot of those same lines
funding for tiny houses is not an
assistant because they're more because
they're temporary structures more of an
RV in that category than they are in the
house there aren't very many lenders who
are willing to lend
you know twenty six thousand dollars or
fifty thousand dollars for a tiny house
because they are worried that you can
always pick up and move it because you
can so in order to for this type of an
idea to really catch on it's more than
just changing the building codes it's
it's the insurance industry has to
reevaluate their policies the lending
industry needs to reevaluate reevaluate
its policies etc
you